monopolise le palmarès sept de ses
chansons se retrouvent dans le top 10
billboard les 25 pièces de son dernier
album se retrouvent dans le top 100
l'album scorpion est le premier au monde
à avoir été écoutée en continu un
milliard de fois sur le web la semaine
dernière jenny et john rich skrenta à
penneteau il a su créer un lien
émotionnel avec les jeunes et les moins
jeunes explique ce rapport c'est un
talent rare dray qui est aussi
l'ambassadeur officiel et aux raptors de
toronto
et c'est lui qui a inventé le nouveau
surnom de la ville de 6 d'après
l'indicatif régional de la ville 4 1 6
[Musique]
grâce à sa musique et à ses vidéos
tournées dans la ville reine drake a
donné à toronto une image de ville
branchée
il donne espoir à tant de jeunes
défavorisés explique cette animatrice
il est leur modèle
la marque drake est si puissante qu'elle
engendre des centaines de millions de
dollars en retombées touristiques à
toronto
ces deux femmes tenait à faire une
escale à toronto avant de rentrer chez
elle amsterdam you want you sont des
fans finis du rapport et elle désirait
voir sa ville
pour elle la tour cn n'est pas la tour
cn c'est la tour drake
car elle se retrouve sur la couverture
d'un de ses albums
l'industrie touristique dans la ville
reine ces 8 milliards 800 millions de
dollars
un consultant en marketing de toronto
estime qu'à lui seul jack serait
responsable de 5% de ses retombées soit
440 millions c'est notre enfant prodige
dit le responsable du développement
économique de toronto et se sert du
rappeur comme argument pour attirer des
investisseurs en parlant de drake il a
récemment capter l'attention
d'investisseurs il a réussi à attirer un
important congrès de haute technologie
retombées estimées pour toronto 147
millions de dollars pour la ville reine
grecque n'est pas qu'un artiste
international c'est son meilleur
ambassadeur ici philippe leblanc radio
canada toronto